if we did not do the things all of us
must now do
if people don't take the stay at home
seriously
the risk at this point in time in the
middle of winter with this new variant
is extraordinarily high
what is going to happen over time is the
risk level is gradually going to
decrease it's not going to be it's it's
really bad and then suddenly it stops
it's we're going to essentially have the
risk walking down a path
things will be able to be lifted by
degrees possibly at different rates in
different parts of the country we'll
have to see
and the government has made very clear
that ministers prioritize education for
example is one of the things that would
go
early but that's a ministerial decision
very much but the things we lifted stage
by stage
and will then get over time to a point
where people say this level of risk is
one that society is prepared to tolerate
and lift you know right down to almost
no
restrictions at all we might have to
bring a few in uh in the next winter for
example that is possible because winter
will
benefit the virus but the aim of this is
to de-risk it as much as possible
by the vaccine to the point where
actually we get to the stage
where the risk is incredibly low
relative to where we are now
i mean we just say just as we do with
flu where every year
roughly on an average year about 7 000
people a year die in
a bad year up to 20 000 people a year
die we accept there is a level of risk
that society
will tolerate and we have we should
tolerate
people die that's one of the things that
happens and we have to do that
at a certain point but that's a
political decision that's a societal
decision
what we can do though with the vaccine
is take the risk down and down initially
with the mortality
then the big pressure on the nhs then
the risk of people actually having
uh infections which could lead to things
like long-covered
because younger people can still have
really serious problems with this
and those risks are little by little be
reduced by vaccination
but zero risk is not something which is
a realistic possibility
and this will not happen in a single
bound it'll happen by degrees